d'après ce que l'on sait la catastrophe
s'est déroulé très vite les campeurs du
grand bornand n'ont pas vraiment eu le
temps de réagir la suite d'un violent
orage
une rivière le borgne est sortie de son
lycée transformées en torrents d'eau
boueuse et a déferlé sur le camping
brutalement le dernier bilan jeudi
bienne est encore provisoire fait état
de 19 morts et de trente disparus
françois chante et on a d'abord cru à
une tornade
hier en fin d'après midi un orage d'une
extrême violence a fait brutalement
monté les eaux d'un petit auront au
moins de dix minutes
une coulée de boue de 20 mètres de large
s'est formé emportant tout sur son
passage
le camping du grand bornand se trouve
sur les rives du petit torrent en
quelques instants voitures caravanes
tentes tout est emportée par le torrent
dévastateur les pans entiers d'une
petite route située au dessus du camping
se sont écroulés tous ces produits si
rapidement les vacanciers n'ont pas eu
le temps de trouver refuge
certains se sont calfeutrés dans leur
caravane d'autres ont escaladé les
parois qui borde le camping pour
échapper à la coulée de boue
et il était impossible de prévoir cette
appli qui met un petit fond de tornade
c'est absolument impossible d'obtenir
cet orage ce trip 2 et de toutes les
conséquences qui en découlent et
d'ailleurs la meilleure des preuves dans
les communes voisines sur le gâteau
valait bien la route départementale a
été emporté sur sur plusieurs centaines
de mètres voire un kilomètre un pont est
importé la retraite est coupée à
plusieurs endroits pas alors que la
route cette route départementale donc
existe depuis début du siècle
très rapidement un plan de secours
d'urgence est déclenché la préfecture de
haute savoie organise les secours
en tout quatre cents sauveteurs sont sur
place pour tenter de retrouver les
nombreux disparus
deux cent vingt sapeurs pompiers
plongeurs ou pour tâche de sonder la
rivière
à l'heure qu'il est on a pu dénombrer 19
morts et 20 disparus
regardez la carte